hey my name is Timo Phillip come from
Hyde River I'm doing right over the hole
all my life I do the sea ice stuff with
working with cherry about a four years
now where I'm not around the ice on the
other side of plague river this is
station one every time I check on maybe
about 15 minutes I check it every every
one of them all these and that and snow
I get here I Graaff generator and pull
it in there and start it up and I
measure the cable on the two by two by
two and how thick the ice they always
different even though they very close
both three feet apart they always
different on snow after that and I
shovel this one and I drove it on the
ice nine ninety degrees and I put this
temperature
this temperature to the to the whole the
one light grill it and the temperature
knows that ice how cold it is after that
I measure the snow a mission like 5
centimeter every time 5 centimeter I
measured it and temperature keep
different different all the time I try
to use the same hole all the time
because every time I got got hair I try
to keep using it even though when it's
get snow snoring that that thing that
pole right here it's we know cuts that
wrong one right here it's harder one
that it's always inside it's soft one
that's why we try to keep using a safe
same direction all the time I enjoy it
because I have to stay in outside a
little bit and I have to I have to know
that ice thickness to and how how
different every eat every year how
different one that's why I like it